In the US, a US court turned down an emergency appeal by the White House...
...to keep in place President Donald Trump's temporary immigration ban for seven countries.
In the Philippines, citing environmental reasons,...
...the environment minister issues a decision to close half of the country's mines.
In Romania, protests continue to surge in Bucharest...
...despite the government's repeal of a controversial corruption decree.
In Colombia, Fuerzas Armadas Revolucionarias de Colombia or FARC rebels...
...continue their trek towards demobilization camps.
And finally from Turkey, 400 suspected members of the Islamic State are detained...
...in anti-terror raids carried out in six provinces.